The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So the way that I
envision recitations going is
I'll start off kind of reviewing
some of the points,
some of the high points from
lectures, might go into detail
on some of the more
important topics.
And this is also a time for
you to ask questions.
There's only 25-30 of you here,
so you should feel a
little bit more comfortable
asking questions.
And there are no stupid
questions here.
For the most part, you're all
beginners at programming.
Am I wrong?
Has anyone programmed
here before?
OK.
So presumably, none of you have
any experience with what
we're talking about.
And so if you ask a question, no
matter how basic you think
it is, it's not stupid.
Because everyone's been there,
including me and the professor
when we started programing.
And we've made, ourselves,
really stupid mistakes too.
So.
That said.
We started out by talking
about the purpose of the
class, which is to teach you
how to take problems, real
world problems, break them down,
abstract them, and divvy
them up so that you can solve
them with a computer.
And when we talk about computer,
we're talking about
a very simple model where--
and this is the only time you'll
see anything related to
hardware in this class.
When we talk about a computer,
we're talking about something
very simple with a CPU and
memory and maybe some input
and output.
All right.
And when we talk about programs,
these are sequences
of instructions that are loaded
into the computer's
memory which can be divided up
into little cells like this.
All right.
And what they might
look like is--
This actually doesn't mean
anything, but it's just, you
know, for the sake
of demonstration.
This is what a computer
would see.
As the CPU starts running
a program, it looks at
whatever's in this memory
location and says, this is an
instruction I can handle,
so I'm gonna go do this.
So this might be like add
two numbers together
and produce a result.
Something very simple,
very basic.
And as it moves along in a
straight line fashion, it just
executes this instruction,
this instruction, this
instruction, et cetera,
et cetera.
The problem is is that while
the computer is perfectly
happy to look at this, this
is gibberish to us.
And most people, most sane
people, if they're actually
looking at computer code,
can't decipher this.
So this is where programming
languages come in.
We can move up a level.
We can abstract away from this,
and maybe say something
like this stands for --
move a number into a register
or something like that.
You don't have to know
what this means.
All you have to know is that
this is a little bit more
readable than this.
And it represents an instruction
that the computer
can understand.
The problem is that even at this
level, this is still very
atomic and very low level, and
really you can't understand
what's going on.
So--
just so I can fill this in.
We move into say, I'm gonna say
x is equal to 1 and I'm
gonna add x plus 5 and
then multiply by 2.
This is a lot easier for
us to understand.
And this is what we're talking
about when we're talking about
any sort of programming
language that we'll be
studying in this course.
And we're studying Python.
So there are hundreds of
languages that allow you to
express these concepts in
a form similar to that.
And all it does is it allows us
to talk to the computer in
this language.
So everyone good with that?
Cool?
All right.
So when we have these
programming languages, they're
put together in specific ways.
So does everyone remember
the term syntax?
Can anyone tell me what it meant
or means in terms of
programming languages?
AUDIENCE: I could guess.
It is the way that the
string is structured?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's the way the parts of the
language are put together.
So let's say that I take a
very simple statement.
I'm taking a variable
plus this variable.
This is a valid piece of
syntax for Python, for
example, or, say, arithmetic,
or a bunch
of different languages.
So this is good.
I can't write.
On the other hand, if we say
variable variable plus, this
isn't valid in Python,
for example.
It might be valid in another
language, but the syntax of
Python won't allow this.
So this is bad syntax.
So.
All right.
So is everyone kind of
understand what syntax is?
All right.
What about static semantics?
Talked about that in class.
Can anyone give me kind of a
rough view of what that is?
Can I choose someone?
All right.
When we talk about static
semantics, we're talking about
syntactically valid statements
that mean something.
So let's say that I have
variable a is equal to 5 and b
is equal to 2.
A statement that's syntactically
correct and is
also meaningful with respect to
static semantics could be
something like a divided
by 2, right.
Or a divided by b.
They're valid statements
syntactically.
And we know that 5 divided by
2 or a divided by b, they're
both numbers.
They mean something.
On the other hand, let's
say that I had this.
I'm gonna say that this variable
d is a string 'foo'.
All right.
This c divided by d where c is
a number and d is a string,
that's something that's
not meaningful, right.
What does a number divided
by a string mean?
Nothing.
So that's what we're talking
about with static semantics.
So bad.
These two aspects of computer
programs are pretty easy to
check for a compiler interpreter
because they're
pretty explicit rules, right.
The part that we spend most
of our time in is
the semantic part.
And this is where the syntax
checks out, the statements are
meaningful in and of themselves,
but the program as
a whole, or the whole kind
of recipe, doesn't work.
So as an example, so this,
as we know is fine.
That's correct.
But let's say we have this.
So a is 6, c is 0.
I do that, what's
6 divided by 0?
It's an error.
But syntactically
this is fine.
And by static semantics,
So this is the type of thing
we're talking about with the
semantic aspects of a program.
Does it work properly?
And before I jump into Python,
one tip to keep in mind is
that when you're writing
programs and you're trying to
do your problem sets, your
program is very explicit.
It's not ambiguous.
So a program will do what
you tell it to do and
no more and no less.
And a statement doesn't
mean two things.
So like if I make the statement
in English, I cannot
say enough good things or
recommend this person highly
enough, if you write that out
that can be considered a
statement with two different
meanings.
One of them is not too
complimentary.
All right.
So when you're writing your
programs, if it's not doing
what you think it's doing, one
of the skills that you need to
learn throughout the semester is
to be able to read the code
and try to follow along in your
mind what's going on.
It's not magic.
OK.
So now we're at Python.
We're past kind of the generic
introductory scaffolding stuff.
Now we're onto something that's
actually gonna be
meaningful for you for the
next 12, 13, 14 weeks.
All right.
So Python is a general
purpose language.
It's used for all sorts of
things, web development, small
device development, desktop
programs, et cetera.
It's an interpreted language,
which means that if I have a
program, blah, blah, blah, blah,
then Python executes it
for me straight away.
Some languages, compiled
languages, have to go through
a compiler, and then you
have to run them.
All right.
It's an extra step.
The nice thing about having an
interpreted language is that
as you may changes to the code,
you can instantly see
what's going on with
your program.
So.
See.
It's got a very simple syntax.
And it's also very widely used
and has been getting--
more and more people have
started using it, oh, for the
past, say, 15 years.
So.
10 years ago when I first heard
about it, it was kind of
like this little
cute language.
Now it's kind of blossomed into
this wonderful language
that everyone uses and loves.
So.
Programs in Python, and in all
languages, are sequences of
expressions.
So this is getting
back to syntax.
And these expressions, they are
composed of operands and
operators and functions.
So let's say, for example,
this is an expression.
This is a variable name.
This is the assignment
operator, and
this is a string literal.
When I say operand, what
I'm referring to are
things in the language.
That's what a literal
and a variable are.
And then if I say operator, this
is something that does
something to things.
So it's--
this is an example of what we
call an assignment operator.
What it does is it says, take
what I'm referring to my right
hand side here, create a name
called myvar, and say that
every time that I reference
myvar, I get this value.
We'll talk more about
that later on.
Um.
Let's see.
Where am I going?
So one important thing to know
about Python is that
everything--
so these things--
are objects.
For now, you don't have to get
too familiar with what an
object is just--
if you know anything, especially
for the first quiz,
this is something to know.
These objects, they
have types, right.
So some types that we have
in Python are ints.
What are examples of
ints or integers?
What?
AUDIENCE: 7.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Just rattle a few off.
So 7, 0, negative
1, 2, et cetera.
Now there's another number
type, floats, right.
So this is what we normally
think of as real numbers.
But when you're talking about
real numbers on the computer,
they are kind of dicey to deal
with-- and we'll actually
cover that later on in the
semester when we talk about
kind of the inexactness
of these.
But for now, just know that
these are numbers with like
decimal points.
All right.
OK.
Where am I going next?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Actually,
syntactically, yes.
So one thing that you might
encounter when you're dealing
with your programs-- this is
kind of off on a tangent--
is when you say assign a number
to a variable, when you
have a literal like this number
here, 0, Python infers
what type you're
talking about.
So in this case, it's gonna
create a number, and it's
gonna call it a type integer.
All right.
If it sees this, it's gonna
create this variable, and it's
gonna have a type of float.
Now, it might seem like
something minor to you right
now, but when you start doing
some of the math on problem
set one, if you divide by an
integer, you might run into
problems, right, because in
computer-land 5 integer
divided by 2 integer
is equal to 2.
Whereas in the real world,
it's equal to that.
So just be aware when you're
working with numbers that you
need to be aware of their type,
all right, especially
when you're talking about the
different operations you can
do on them.
So.
So for these number types, you
have addition, subtraction,
multiplication, division.
For integers, exponentiation,
which is
represented by two asterisks.
And for integers, modulo.
And then for floats
plus, minus, same
thing except no modulo.
All right.
So back to the list.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
a quick question?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you explain
why like maybe briefly 5
divided by 2 is 2?
You said in computer-land,
like what?
Is it doing some sort
of weird rounding?
Or like why, why is that
different than--?
PROFESSOR: This is because
the type of the
variable is an integer.
And when you say something is
an integer, you're talking
about only these
numbers, right.
So 2 and a 1/2 as an integer
doesn't exist.
It only exists as a float.
But when you have an operand
like this that takes two
numbers on both sides, if both
numbers are integers, this
produces a result that
is an integer.
So when you have these math
operators, these produce a
result, right.
So that result has
a type as well.
Because I can take that
result and I say c is
equal to 5 and 1/2.
C is now a variable
in the language.
That means that it has
to have a type.
And Python says that because I
did this operation with two
integers, I'm gonna give it
a type as an integer.
And the closest representation
to 2 and 1/2 in
integer terms is 2.
AUDIENCE: I thought it
would round up to 3.
I assumed that it would round
up to [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
You're talking about
a separate issue.
It's not necessarily that it's
closest, but it truncates.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So when
it converts--
yeah, it just truncates
the decimal.
AUDIENCE: What happens if you
have 5 divided by 2--
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So when you get into
stuff like that, Python's
gonna look at, see it's an
integer and a float, and--
this is something that we're
gonna have to actually test
out when I turn on
the computer.
It should convert to a float,
but it might not.
So.
We'll test that out, actually.
That's one of the nice things
about Python is that if you
have a question like that,
you can test it out
instantaneously.
So remind me ints divided
by float, and
we'll demonstrate it.
OK.
All right.
So another data type, string.
Anyone know what a string
is or can tell me?
Shout it out.
Pantomime it.
AUDIENCE: Sequence
of characters.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So it's something like this.
All right.
And you can--
does anyone mind if
I erase this?
So in Python, you can specify
strings a couple ways.
One is with single quotes
on the sides.
And the other is with
double quotes.
This is useful, for example,
if you need to embed quotes
inside a string.
So if I need to, say, have this
as a quoted string, I
would have single quotes on the
outside and then double
quotes on the inside,
or vice versa.
I could do double quotes
and then single quotes.
The point is that Python needs
to know when and where the
string starts and where
the string ends.
We good?
All right.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So if you put that?
If you write this, Python's
gonna call that a string.
It's a string that contains
the character two, though.
All right.
I guess you're asking
because of the input
with the problem set?
AUDIENCE: --divide that by a
string, by an integer that
would [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So in your program,
there's a point where you have
to enter in numbers
for problem set 1.
Oh, you didn't start?
Well there is a place where
you have to enter numbers.
So raw_input, for example, is
gonna return a variable, and
the type of this is
gonna be a string.
So if you need to use it as an
integer or as a float, you can
convert it.
So now this is an integer, and
you can do math with it.
Or you can also say--
Does that make sense?
That's something that'll be
useful in your problem set.
So just FYI.
All right.
Another data type, Boolean.
Does anyone know what
a Boolean is?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: It's like an
if-then statement?
PROFESSOR: It has to
do with if-then
statements, but it's a variable.
It's a type that only has two
values, true or false.
OK.
And we'll talk about this, all
of these, when I start talking
about operations on them.
Last one that you need to know
of right now is the none type.
The way to think about none
is that it's sort
of like dark matter.
It's there.
We know it's there.
It holds a place, but we can't
do anything with it.
It's there just so that you know
that there's a variable
that should refer to something
but that something doesn't
exactly exist.
OK.
You'll see more of it.
But it's nothing,
but it's there.
And then later on
in the semester,
there's other data types.
I mean, there's a lot of data
types, but these are the big
ones that you need to
know right now.
Other data types that we might
look at are lists, tuples, and
dictionaries.
These are other major data
types in Python.
You don't need to know them
right now 'cause Professor
Guttag will go over
them in lecture.
But just keep them
in your brain.
OK.
So we've already talked about
the operations that we can do
on numbers.
We can also do operations
on strings.
So we can do something
called concatenation.
So concatenation is just
a big word for
sticking two things together.
So if I have s1 and s2 and I
want to concatenate them to
together, I use the
plus operator.
So the other thing, too, that I
want to point out is that we
have a plus operator for ints.
We got a plus operator
for float.
We've got one for strings.
I don't think they work for
bools, but they work for lists
and tuples.
This is what's known as an
overloaded operator.
So it changes shape or changes
its behavior depending on the
data types of its operands.
So that's why when you're
dividing an ints by a float,
some languages will convert
it to a float for you.
Other languages will
convert to an ints.
It's something that varies.
That's why I'm not sure of
my answer right now.
So.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
If your computer blows
up in your face,
then that's an issue.
That's a separate issue.
All right.
So some other operations that
we have, and they relate to
Booleans, are comparison
operations.
What these mean are these take
two operands and compare them.
So if I want to see if--
if I say a less than b and a is
2 and b is 3, then this is
gonna return true.
The value of this expression
becomes true.
And if I say a greater than
b, obviously it's
gonna be false, right.
And all of these operators
work in
basically the same way.
They take two operations,
and they give you a
Boolean value back.
All right.
Any questions on that?
AUDIENCE: So are Boolean values
always true or false?
PROFESSOR: Always
true or false.
And I'm actually gonna
get to that now.
So Boolean values-- and this is
kind of the last major one
we're gonna talk about--
have three operators,
AND, OR, and NOT.
Actually, these should
be lowercase.
These, AND and OR, take two
operands, NOT takes one.
And what they do is if you have
something like a is true,
b is true, c is false, if you
say like a AND b, then this
entire expression is gonna
return true, right.
If I say a AND c, this
will be false.
AND returns true, if and only
if both operands are true,
false otherwise.
If you say a OR c, OR returns
true if both operands or one
operand is true.
So if any of them are true
or both are true.
If they're both false, then
it returns false.
And NOT, all this does is if I
say NOT a, it'll return false.
It reverses it.
Now we can combine
these together.
So these are very simple
expressions, but we can also
combine them.
So we can say like a
AND b OR c, right.
So if both a amd b are true,
then this becomes true.
And then this entire expression
becomes true if
this part is true or
this part is true.
So you can build up pretty
complicated expressions.
And then the way that they
relate to these logical
operators is, remember, these
take numbers on either side
and they produce
Boolean values.
So if I have--
I can say d is less than e.
This is gonna give me a Boolean
value, right, which I
can then use the AND operator
on and I can say--
So what this does is it says if
d is less than e and e is
less than f, then return true.
This, by the way, would check to
see that these numbers are
in order, so 3, 4, 5, as
opposed to 5, 4, 3.
So is everyone good
on all that?
Did I lose anyone?
No questions?
All right.
So the last couple of things and
then I'm gonna turn on the
computer and actually walk
through some code with you and
we'll be done for the day.
So this is kind of the crash
course in basic syntax for our
basic types for Python.
So there were three--
So what we have now is a way to
create programs that run in
a straight line, right.
So can anyone give me kind of a
synopsis of what a straight
line program is?
AUDIENCE: Go down
line by line.
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Everything one--
go down line by line.
PROFESSOR: Go down line by
line, do everything once.
All right.
The problem is that this
doesn't allow us to do
anything, right.
So we have branching.
This is implemented
by something
called an IF statement.
Now, the way you use an
IF statement is--
all right.
This is the full version
of the IF statement.
It's saying, if this condition
is true, I'm gonna execute the
code in this block.
If this condition is true, if
this condition is false and
this condition is true,
then I'm gonna
execute the code here.
And if none of those
were true, then I
execute what's here.
You don't need to have an ELIF,
and you don't need to
have an ELSE.
You can just have an IF
or an IF and an ELSE.
So the three versions
of this branching--
Now when I, just by way of
explanation, when I draw like
a line like that, I'm talking
about a block of code.
Can anyone tell me how Python
represents blocks of code?
AUDIENCE: Indents?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So indentation, right.
We kind of talked about
that on Thursday.
So blocks of code are chunks
of code that belong kind of
logically together.
So what this saying is that if I
execute this, all this block
is gonna get executed, all this
block is going to get
executed, et cetera.
So if I were to represent this
pictorially, then this is kind
of the main part of the program
and then this is the
if statement and the block.
And then it goes back
to whatever code
is down here, right.
If I represent this
pictorially, this
would be the true part.
So this part of code,
this would be else.
And then this part would
be multiple excursions.
So it would look a little
bit like a tree.
All right.
So different branches for the
different bits of code.
Is everyone puzzled on that?
Or anyone puzzled on that?
OK.
And there was a last
bit of flow control
that we talked about.
What was it?
So if we want to do something
multiple times?
AUDIENCE: Iterations or loops
PROFESSOR: Iterations
or loops, right.
So it's called a loop because
it looks like a loop in the
code, right.
And there's two variants.
There's a WHILE loop and
there's a FOR loop.
A FOR loop is when you want
to iterate over a
finite set of elements.
So what this FOR loop does is
it says I'm gonna take--
this is the range function,
so we'll talk about this
a little bit later.
But all it does is it gives me
all the numbers from 1 to 9.
It goes 1 past.
So.
But you don't need to
know it just yet.
What this is telling Python,
though, is that we're gonna
execute this block of code
9 times, all right.
And on each iteration through
this block of code, we're
gonna set i to 1, and then set
it to 2, set it to 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10.
Anyone lost by that?
We'll see an example of
it pretty shortly.
And then the last one
is a WHILE loop.
A WHILE loop executes as long
as a condition is true.
So it's useful--
don't want to do that.
It's useful when you're not
necessarily iterating over
this finite set of elements or
you don't necessarily know how
many times you need to execute
a specific loop.
You just know that you need to
keep executing this code while
something is true.
And we'll see an example
of that pretty quickly.
So I basically shotgun blasted a
whole bunch of stuff at you.
Is there anything that people
want me to touch on before I
pull down the screen and we
start looking at code?
All right.
So has everyone been able
to get Python set up?
All right.
So you'll know that this is
the editor window, right.
So what we use to edit
longer scripts in?
And you know that this is
the interactive prompt.
Before I forget, let's see what
happens if I divide the
integer 5 by the float 2.
So Python does what you would
hope it would do.
It turns it into a float.
If I do this, though,
it gives me 2.
All right.
So it's an easy way to test.
So we've got two chunks
of code here that
I want to go over.
One of them, you've
already seen.
It's the program that tries
to find the cube root of a
perfect cube.
And why don't we just walk
through it and read the code?
All right.
So here's that raw_input
function
that I told you about.
Now, it's gonna take a string
and it's gonna print the
string out on the screen
and it's gonna
say enter an integer.
And, comment this out.
So let's enter--
what's a perfect cube?
All right, the return type of
raw_input is a string, right.
So that int will convert to x.
Now, here's an example of
a loop, the WHILE loop.
And because we don't have
knowledge of what the user's
gonna input when the program
is run, a while loop is an
appropriate kind of control
loop to use, right.
Because we can test a condition
where our guess,
which is what's represented by
ans, if we cube it, is it
still less than x.
All right.
I explained that a little
bit incorrectly.
What we're doing here is we're
making a guess, and we're
calling it ans right now,
and we're gonna set it
initially to zero.
And then we're gonna enter
this WHILE loop and we're
gonna say we're gonna take
answer and we're gonna
multiply it three times.
We're gonna cube it.
And if the value of ans cubed
is less than whatever input
the user gave us, then we're
gonna keep looping.
And on each loop, we're gonna
increase the value of our
guess for ans, right.
And if it turns out that x is a
perfect cube, eventually, by
just iterating through all the
integers from 1 to whatever,
whatever the cube root of x is,
we will find the answer.
And we'll know we find the
answer because answer cubed is
going be less than x.
Now, can anyone tell me
why we have abs here?
AUDIENCE: The absolute value.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So let's say that the user
entered in like negative 27.
It still has a cube, right.
It's still negative 3.
But the way that we set up our
loop, if we were to take this
out, the program would just
continue executing forever.
Well, for actually a very,
very long time, but--
the universe would die
before this finished.
So we have this absolute
value here.
Is anyone puzzled by this?
Do I need to belabor
the point?
OK.
So eventually I've entered
27 and we can actually--
a good way to kind of check
ourselves is to print out
diagnostic input.
So if guess is 1, that's not--
1 cubed is obviously not 27.
2 cubed is not 27.
3 cubed is 27.
And when we get to that point,
we leave the loop.
And now we're down in
this bit of code.
All right.
Now, because we're asking for
cube roots, we need to check
the condition for when the--
sorry, I'm kind of
mixed up here.
Sorry.
So when we exit the WHILE loop,
if we've had a number
that's not a perfect cube, then
we know that the value
the answer stopped on is not
going to equal the cube of it,
by way of explanation.
So my last guess
3 cubed is 27.
Let's run it again.
Let's say that I
have 20, right.
So what happens is
it gets to 4.
So 4 cubed is 64, right.
That's obviously not 28.
And that's what this
condition checks.
And so it knows that if it gets
to that point, it's not a
perfect cube.
Now, this ELIF statement here
says, OK, so if this turns out
to be true, that means that
it wasn't a perfect cube.
But let's say that it was a
perfect cube, this will be
true, and Python will then start
to look at this and say,
well, let's look at this if
condition, or actually--
I'm sorry.
This condition will be false if
it's a perfect cube, right.
And Python will say, OK, look
at the next part of the
IF-ELIF statement and will say,
well, was x less than 0?
What it's doing here, it's
checking whether or not we've
entered a negative
number or not.
So if we enter negative 27, what
it would do is it would
to enter this branch, and then
it would negate whatever
answer it got.
Because we found the answer
for a positive
perfect cube, right.
Did I break it?
We are having technical
difficulties.
Oh, OK.
I'm not sure what
happened there.
So anyway.
So we go about trying to find
the cube root of 27, which is
the absolute value of 27.
And we, of course, find it.
It's 3.
But then because we've entered
a negative number, Python's
gonna enter this branch and
negate whatever answer we got.
Because we know that in order
for it to be negative, then it
would have to have been a
negative number, right.
Is anyone lost?
Everyone good?
AUDIENCE: Do you need an
exclamation mark for the--?
PROFESSOR: Oh, this one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So this is one of
the comparison operators.
This stands for not equal to.
So if I have--
do a little Python work here--
if I have a is equal to 5 and
b is equal to 6, if I say a is
double equal, that's gonna
check and see if they're
the same value.
Obviously, they're not, so
it's gonna return false.
On the other hand, if I say
not equal-- or bang equal
sometimes we call--
this will return true.
OK.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: The one that you did
28 for, shouldn't it not print
the cube root of 28 is 4?
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Should it be indented?
Because if we indented
here, right, then
what's gonna happen?
It's only gonna print
out the cube root
for negative numbers.
So what--
what's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, again, if we
put an ELSE statement, then it
won't print out the cube root
for negative numbers.
What we could do, and this is
kind of a hackish way, is
write it like this.
But that's kind of ugly,
right, because you're
repeating yourself.
And one thing about computer
programmers is that we are the
laziest people on the
face of the earth.
Like, we'll spend 20 hours
writing a program to do
something in five minutes that
we could have originally done
in 10 minutes.
It's just our nature.
So anyway.
So we're repeating ourselves.
And while I'm speaking,
this is the
solution I came up with.
If I were to go back and rewrite
this, I'd probably
make it a little bit
less convoluted.
So maybe, let's try this.
So we're gonna check if we
were successful, and then
we're gonna check if
x is less than 0.
Now we're not repeating
ourselves.
And we catch all the cases.
So let's make sure that my fix
works because oftentimes when
you write programs, you'll
introduced bugs of your own.
So we've tested when
it is a cube.
Let's test it when it's not.
OK.
So there we fixed it, I think.
One thing about computer
programs is that this is a
very simple case, but for
longer, more complicated
programs, it's almost
impossible to get
out all of the bugs.
But in this case, pretty
confident that we were
successful, right.
So does anyone else have
any other questions
on this bit, right?
All right.
The last thing that I'm gonna go
over is something called a
fizzbuzz program.
This is just a silly
little program.
This is the English
specification.
And this is kind of a first
instance of where we're gonna
take English and kind of break
it down into code, figure out
how to break it up, chunk it
up, and abstract it into
something that actually works.
So the problem is to write a
program the prints the numbers
from 1 to 100, but for multiples
of three, print fizz
instead of the number.
And for multiples of
5, print buzz.
And if there are multiples are
both 3 and 5, print fizzbuzz.
So if it says numbers from 1 to
100, when you see something
like this when you're trying
to figure out how to write
your programs, the first thing
that should go off in your
mind is, I probably need a for
loop because I'm iterating
over a set of numbers.
So we happen to know the
numbers 1 to 100.
And here's a range
function again.
And we'll talk about range
next week most likely.
And all we're gonna do is first
we're gonna get the
string value of this number.
So remember how earlier you
asked if, or one of the
students asked, if we had a
number in the string, if that
was a number or not?
So like this.
That's what that STR
function does.
So if I have a variable a is
equal to 1, I can say s is
equal to STR a, and s is
now gonna be that.
All right.
And then what I'm gonna do here
is I'm gonna check the
integer value, so i, and
see if it's evenly
divisible by 3 or 5.
And the way that I
checked that is I
use a modulo operator.
That's what that percent
sign is.
What this operator does is it
takes two integer values and
it returns the remainder after
you've divided the left
integer by the right integer.
So if I have 6 modulo 3,
what's that gonna be?
It should be 0, right, because
you can divide 6 evenly by 3.
The other hand, if I say 5
modulo 3, then that's going to
be 2, right.
Yeah, I had to think about
it for a second.
OK.
So that's all this does.
And these are two expressions
that return a
Boolean value, right.
Because this modulo operation
is gonna return an integer,
and I'm gonna use the equality
operator to compare it to a
number, another integer, 0,
and that's gonna give me a
Boolean value.
This expression also gives
me a Boolean value.
And then I'm gonna combine
them into--
using the or operator
for Boolean values--
into a larger expression.
And then if this is true, then
I know that I'm gonna have to
at lease print fizz,
buzz, or fizzbuzz.
Because I'm not gonna print
the number, right, because
it's a multiple of 3 or 5.
And so all this code does is
just figures out if it's
evenly divisible by 3, then
I know I print fizz.
So I'm gonna concatenate my
final string onto it.
And then if it's evenly
divisible by 5, then I know I
need to print buzz.
So then I'm gonna attach
buzz onto my output.
And then I'm just gonna print
whatever I'm left over with.
So to see this in action
because we are way out
of time right now.
So 1, 2, fizz, 4, buzz,
6, fizz, 7, 8.
Then we have fizzbuzz for 15.
So it seems to work.
Everyone follow that?
We good?
So I'm done for this
recitation.